in this particular moment I think Dragon
Ball is definitely up there
can I make something can I say something
that might be controversial okay what
now go give it 20 years or maybe even
like 15 years do you think that more
people are going to be talking and
remembering the end of one piece than
than Dragon Ball because Dragon Ball was
obviously our era but if you're assuming
one piece is going to end it is good
that's the thing though that's the thing
it is going to end one piece will be
ending within the next 10 years I think
I would have said 10 years ago okay
well like he he sees the kind of guy who
won't let it quit yeah no no I mean it's
it's like maybe okay okay I feel that's
a great question but I feel the
comparison is also slightly unfair
because roughly you know like whenever
the [__] one piece ends like let's say
in the next five years if one piece ends
right like five years from now or
already even now compared to when Dragon
Ball ended right the landscape of the
anime fandom internationally has just
exploded right like the the like you
know when whenever Dragon Ball ended I
don't even remember when it was but like
you know when that ended the especially
the international anime Community was
not as like heavily invested or was like
openly talking about anime in the same
way that they are talking about it today
yeah right so I feel that comparison is
slightly unfair and to answer your
question more people will be talking
about one piece just because it's gonna
end in a period where people are [__]
like it's like Dragon Ball never got to
the point where it was trending on
Twitter no no no you know but like okay
Soca like here's like my like thinking
around this because obviously Dragon
Ball [__] Global sensation hugely
influential now we uh this is something
that got many people into anime
um but I think we're gonna see something
interesting when one piece comes to an
end because it's going to be the very
first globally popular franchise because
one piece somehow is only getting more
and more popular now as it's gone on
yeah
um it's going to be a show that has gone
on for like 20 30 years and people will
have grown up with one piece and seen it
come to his conclusion and I think the
[__] power of that when it ends is
something that I can't think of another
franchise that will like come close to
grasping that kind of power where you
have a whole generation of anime fans
now that are going to grow up see one
piece come to its conclusion and that's
going to be the most important like kind
of show that's stuck with them in their
lives I mean I guess like Naruto kind of
got close in that sense but you can't we
can't decide the the the Wonders based
on what could happen might be a new
Wonder it might be a new one I just feel
like yeah one piece hasn't ended so he
can't have that conversation yeah yeah
okay so right now right now Dragon Ball
fans you have the throne so who's to say
they want [__] like boruto that [__]
you know what I mean they'll be like
yeah
if he had a kid and uh the thing is that
he's made of stone instead of rubber
and it's called Rock piece
like I I just dude I just feel like one
piece they'll never let it die I feel
like they're gonna do something with it
you know what I mean yeah I mean they're
already like doing you know like
spin-off like side character based like
manga series and stuff like that yeah I
mean they did they did a whole one for
Ace and like his backstory so yeah [__]
me yeah illustrated by the uh guy who
made Dr CERN
which is actually really good I would
recommend it okay okay yeah I I didn't
know that was a thing
even I read that yeah yeah okay okay so
like all right yeah they're probably
gonna end up doing that but as of right
now we can't really yeah that's the
other thing we should figure out
like is currently ongoing series
acceptable to be put into the mount rush
I think if they've had the big enough
impact okay but I think one I think one
piece hasn't had the same impact as
Dragon Ball not yet but I think I think
if I think there's there might be a
point in the future where it does have
the same impact to like a generation
dragons maybe even more yeah I think
it's I think it's like it's like the
same level honestly right now yeah um
you better watch out Dragon Ball fans
the one piece fans haven't had anything
good in like 10 years I still care I
don't watch anything in 10 years by the
way I don't know I was judging that
based off the fact that nobody has
mentioned that anything Dragon Ball
recently is good to me no the Broly
movie was good oh I've heard that though
okay so okay if we're talking in terms
then do you feel like Akira deserves to
be on the more than like no I just
wanted to say it so that my ass is
covered when Akira fans cover this yeah
I mean I was like guys I tried it I okay
I post think yes I think Akira deserves
to be on there more than Spirited Away
right just purely because like oh yeah I
just want to give him any credit well I
mean look as much as I love Spirited
Away like and you know it did win an
Oscar and everything but like I think
just like the pure impact of Akira not
just within the anime fandom but like
outside the anime fandom was just like
[__] insane like there are so many
people where you'd be like you would
never associate with liking anime or
knowing anything about anime who are
like yeah Akira [__] first of all
boss baby was nominated for an Oscar so
I feel like using Oscars as a base also
Shrek won an Oscar which is great
I'm saying this is kind of ballpark
everywhere the boss baby got nominated
Oscars yeah I feel like that's not a
good metric but um yeah and I'm sure
more anime would have caught the
nominated of course back then if they
weren't so kind of closed off to four
okay if you don't think Akira should be
up there then what if if you had to pick
a movie
to pick one movie was it let's let's see
what you guys feel about if you had to
pick one anime movie to be on the Mount
Rushmore which would it be I would pick
a cure
yeah probably be Akira I mean we're
picking between the camera on the first
time
hear me out guys actually go to the
actually change the game the one with me
too where he's like I am too strong
Pikachu crying hear me out guys Demon
Slayer
the top grossing anime movie of all time
hello the metrics don't lie hello data
doesn't care about your feelings Joey
called inflation okay who's making more
money
but yeah okay if we're doing movies
there's only gonna be one there's
there's only like two options it's
either gonna be a Ghibli movie or a
Kiara and I am lukewarm on both so I
yeah I don't know strong feelings about
anime movies I just don't care for them
I mean my favorite anime movies are like
satoshikon movies but unfortunately
that's like the more when you go more
down into like the rabbit hole Yeah
that's like the Citizen Kane of the
anime world yeah yeah
no it's like page three of IMDb
um what other genres are we missing so
we've done Shonen did we agree on a
movie or not yeah yeah okay we actually
agree on a camera now right we've got
Kyra so we got Dragon Ball and Akira
right now and we couldn't agree on a
Mecca one if you guys really it's
between Gundam and Ava if you really if
you guys really really want it I'll give
it okay Mecca I feel is like you know
that is like very uniquely anime I feel
you know so I feel like one of them has
to be up there yeah the question is
which one okay okay but here's in this
specific kind of like scenario
and this specific scenario
um I'm I don't think Ava should be in
the mecca category yeah
it's kind of this is kind of more like
you know especially anyone both on there
sorry are you saying you want both of
them
and we can stop taking stuff out and put
it yeah yeah I do want both on there do
you agree that Astro Boy was up there no
no no okay no so because we already have
four on the list now we've got them Ava
Akira and uh what's the fourth Pokemon
um
okay everything we've listed is pretty
old even though we said we weren't going
to put old anime on there
we have no we have not put a new one the
newest one is actually an Ava is there a
new anime you guys have put on there
get the [__] down here
get Gojo's face off of like [__] rap
Mount Rushmore man listen there's a
reason why everyone loves it
um I don't know new anime
like within the past decade
I mean maybe
uh
this is when it gets hard yeah we only
have three [__] slots left on the
stupid list well we can we can change
things around we can change things
around
is there any other nominations you want
to bring up corner would you like to
bring up Jojo I was thinking of hentai
but I wish to do it as hentai Seven
Wonders later
that's also an idea we can do later yeah
um I mean JoJo's could be up there but
it's for very different reasons than any
of the other ones I feel like JoJo's
kind of been like the Pinnacle of weird
art style having its own carving its own
Niche and kind of pushing a very weird
side of anime forward uh right and as
well as the impact on the fandom at
least in the west and also in Japan I
mean as well yeah majuto is just so it's
Jojo
yeah do you feel like Attack on Titan
should be up there
I think it's done yeah it depends
because I don't know the ending yet so
it really depends on how it's gonna end
yeah you know I mean I feel like
it probably oh my God I mean if it ends
within the next five years and they stop
[__] November okay finally yeah I
think
it probably does
but it's kind of hard it feels weird
putting it on I don't know why it feels
weird why does it feel weird putting it
on because one hasn't ended yet and two
we don't know the true impact of Attack
on Titan yet is it going to be something
like Breaking Bad where we still meme on
it uh like [__] 10 years down the
line probably will it still have
cultural significance it's hard to tell
it's gonna be a really [__] fun show
to go back and watch all the way through
again I and I've yeah I've been watching
it seasonally yeah yeah for my entire
life so it's gonna be fun to be able to
watch it back to back yeah yeah oh it
was great when I showed Sydney Attack on
Titan because she had somehow never seen
Attack on Titan uh just watching it like
binge watching it seasonally uh like
each season and just seeing how the show
has evolved was just like oh I forgot
how [__] good it was uh especially
now that when we the way it's being
released now you forget how hype and how
much has been built up and how much the
story just like interconnects together
sure uh and how much was foreshadowed
it's it was like a pleasure to to watch
it's just crazy that it came out 10
that's what blows my mind the most yeah
um yeah I don't know I feel like
other anime that could be up there I
feel like maybe it just doesn't feel
right to put it up there yet I feel like
I probably if we had this conversation
in four years it definitely would yeah
but I feel like we can do better all
right then I got a new nomination okay
Sailor Moon that's
that's just my childhood [__] you that's
just such a are you guys gonna make a
top 10 anime list of all time
revolutionize the Shoujo genre
revolutionize the magical girl genre did
you make it it did yeah so I mean yeah
so it should be up there
yeah can we can we fact check what the
first magical girl anime is
it's not Sailor Moon but it's definitely
popularized popularized it at least to
the West yeah it's just
it's iconic
1966 okay